the ps5 ui was revealed this morning
destiny 2's next-gen upgrades will be
here in december
and borderlands 3 is getting a new
season pass i'm persia and this is your
save state for thursday october 15th
sony has finally revealed the ps5 ui in
a new video giving us a good look into
what we'll be experiencing on day one
similar to the ps4 you'll start up the
ps5 using the ps button
selecting your profile and going to your
dashboard a variety of game specific
features were showcased
like the create button allowing built-in
spoiler warnings for content you capture
activities cards that help you track
your current progress on a level down to
the
minute or let you pick up exactly where
you want to
and for the ps plus subscribers access
to official game help which are videos
that will help steer you in the right
direction when it comes to a specific
level or challenge
there were also a lot of upgrades to
social and sharing features that will
make it
easier than ever to join your friends
games or parties
and you can also view your friends
gameplay via screen share while playing
your own game
what do you think of the new ui we're
less than one month away from the launch
of the ps5 so be sure to catch our
weekly show generation next
where we'll be talking about this and
everything else to come for the new
consoles
destiny 2 beyond light is getting a
next-gen version
but it won't be a launch title it'll be
hitting the ps5
series x and series s on december 8th
all
versions run at 60 fps and have a new
fov slider and better loading times
and support across crosston multiplayer
but only the ps5 and series x versions
will run the game at 4k
the current version of destiny 2 will
also be playable via backwards
compatibility on the new console
so you can still play the game on launch
day just not the true next-gen version
game pass subscribers will also get the
new beyond light expansion which
launches alongside the series xns on
november 10th
borderlands 3 has wrapped up its season
pass with four total
expansions but gearbox announced that
there's still more to come
season pass two will include two more
pieces of dlc
called the designer's cut and the
director's cut plus
new looks for the vault hunters the
designer's cut will include a new skill
tree for each vault hunter and a new
stand-alone mode called arms race but no
word yet
on what will be in the director's cut
the new season pass and the designer's
cut will be available to purchase on
november 10th
borderlands 3 is also getting next-gen
upgrades and you can buy season pass 2
on any current or
next-gen console pricing for the pass or
individual dlcs has not been announced
so stay tuned to gamespot for more info
on that when it happens
that's all for today but if you're
looking for more videos about your
favorite things in games then
be sure to check out our youtube channel
have a great day and we will catch you
on your next save state
see ya
[Applause]
you